[music]
John,
good evening.
Thank you. My name is John Shipton. I'm
Julian Assange's father. I'm in France
uh for to raise uh awareness and support
for Julian in his fight for freedom from
the United Kingdom court system and the
Department of Justice of the United
States.
Julian is uh the editor and chief of
Wikileaks and started publishing
Wikileaks in 2006.
In 2010 had with leaks from Chelsea
Manning back then known as Bradley
Manning [snorts]
of uh Iraq war files, Afghan war files.
uh the qu the quantama bay files,
collateral murder, all of these pushed
Julian to the forefront of fame right
throughout the western world. The uh as
a consequence of the exposures of
crimes. Julian has since 2010 been
pursued by the United States through the
proxy of Sweden, the Swedish prosecuting
authority and the proxy of the United
Kingdom.
Equally, the complicity of Australia,
his home country, because they're
inactive. So, that's the current
circumstances.
If I could sum it up, it's uh uh 12
years of ceaselessounding,
savage malice,
unscrupulous slander and calumny,
vicious hatred have been heaped upon
Julian year after year after year,
particularly in the United Kingdom and
the United States.
Last week, last Thursday, we called into
the prison. Uh each visit takes two
hours, but uh often they don't bring
Julian down. I don't know why. And so we
waited uh uh 40 minutes. So we had about
45 minutes actual time with Julian.
Yeah.
Well, he's in a Julian is in a in a
category A maximum security prison
titled Bell Marsh. It's just out of
London. Only people there are terrorists
or murderers or rapists.
uh the conditions that he lives in are
in a small cell 22 to 23 hours a day.
This is probably categorized under the
Istanbul Accords as solitary
confinement. It's worsened over the
period of CO because the jail
administration
lost a lot of staff who are frightened
of getting sick from CO and uh the
prisoners consequently spend more time
in their cells. However, the prison
allowed Julian more telephone calls. So,
I was able to speak to Julian frequently
uh with timelmited telephone calls.
Maximum 10 minutes, but you could have
10 minutes and wait a couple of hours
and have another 10 minutes.
Well, a couple of years ago when Dupont
Moretti took up Julian's case as a
lawyer, he had a press conference. There
were 24 cameras there from press
services around the world. Uh at that
time I met uh uh Dupont Moretti but uh
unfortunately
my French is school boy French and very
poor and Dupont Moretti doesn't speak
English. So uh we any exchange we had
was through uh Antoine Bay who worked
with uh Deont Moretti. Now that Moretti
is a foreign uh justice minister, he of
course uh must abandon uh supervision of
Julian's case legally. And Anton Vay,
who I like quite a lot now runs the case
for Julian in France.
France.
No, I uh the assistance France gave is
uh by not joining in the worldwide
unscrupulous slander, lies and
calumnies. Fortunately, France didn't do
that. Um France has had its own severe
difficulties over the last couple of
years and as a consequence the
concentration of the French people and
the political elite have been upon
France and its circumstances in the EU
and geopolitically etc. So one doesn't
expect
too much and it's the quality of not
attacking Julian is place France places
France and Germany in the forefront of
being able to assist Julian in the
future.
Americanotropy.
The entropellectuality.
Well, you know, those re revelations
that Wikileaks made and Julian made were
of great service to France in in
enabling France to understand its
current circumstances
relative to the United States and
relative to the United Kingdom and GCHQ
and the NSA.
This is important and in fact vital. But
[snorts]
also it revealed that five of the great
French technological companies had been
plundered of their
secrets ruling and the height of French
technological achievement had moved to
the United States in five essential
areas. Equally, the Wikileaks and Julian
revealed that the European Community
Bank had been listened to their
contemplations and efforts made to move
their contemplations more towards the
benefit of the United States.
Another scandal is the interference in
French electoral processes by the NSA
listening in. Finally, the Kurugra is
the hacking of the president of France
private telephone. Each of these things
causes in my view the French elites to
contemplate their own problems
intensely. How can we stop this?
They have now
a debt of honor in my view to Julian
Assange and Wikileaks that can be
fulfilled and waits there for to be
fulfilled.
uh honor
as I understand it in the French
cultural system is really important and
adjusting that honor will in my view and
I don't wish to pont pontificate I'm not
speaking from a height here I'm speaking
as though we're friends at dinner and
talking about stuff
in my view This is essential
to move France to a position where
French interests can be held foremost
over and above geopolitical associations
with great powers. Uh I just point out
two things that there's now one train
5,000 tunner. So, in the EU, they rose
the limits uh of of one goods train from
4,270
tons to 5,200 tons. That's improving the
links between the carriages. There's one
every hour coming from China into
Rotten, one every hour, 5,000 tons since
June. Before that, it was one every two
hours. So this indicates to us that
[snorts] the future of France
is in an association with the rest of
the continent. The balance of the
continent has moved very close and it's
a continental association rather than a
seabboard association
and that's really I think essential to
understand well I feel it's essential to
understand the reality uh of uh the
opportunity for France to assert itself
in leadership of Europe.
I mean no offense to Germany but Germany
has uh relies on France geopolitically
for obvious reasons. You know the second
world war it has some difficulties. So
[snorts] uh in fact all of Europe rely
on French diplomatic skill and French
leadership in the EU. Uh
I think the other day after the United
States stole $90 billion which is not a
little bit of money
and also it not only steals
$90 billion the money it also steals the
integrated
industrial effort of France and building
submarines is the is I'm told is more
complex than a moon rocket. Okay.
[snorts]
And it has a an an industrial
verticality from the very bottom
metallurgy to the very top electronics.
And France has those capacities.
Well, yes.
Yes.
I've got another question.
[snorts]
VR
Well, [laughter]
oh, well, like you, Bernard, I no longer
have a private life every because you're
in the forefront of broadcasting in
France. You will be looked at overlooked
constantly.
And so I take no notice. They look at
me, but so far, God willing, they
haven't interfered with me. They haven't
put any scandalous notes from my past in
the newspapers. and uh
the chip.
Yeah. So far, so far
so far
I take no notice and I think like you
you take no notice but you do understand
that uh we are watched and if we
go too far in our commentary
we will be destroyed.
We are ready to be destroyed. We are
French.
We are French. We are We don't have any
limits. When When you you push a France
a France a French people, it's like
wake up a devil. And our our
elite don't have any code of honor. But
French people still remains our code.
If I
without a sense of flattery, without any
flattery,
you know, ever since uh the Bastile
fell, uh France has been in the
forefront of [snorts]
working out ways to get out of problems
that the elites force upon us.
[snorts]
I don't want to make enemies of the
elites because they have to help us one
way or another. I depend upon their
decisions.
However, uh the
the underpinning of every society, new
society like uh you can't count England
too much, but our societies the
underpinning is equality, fraternity
and liberty. The underpinning, we speak
about it all the time, democracy and so
on, choice, whatever. Yeah. But it
underpins our attitude. We believe and
we work towards a belief that we have
some liberty. We have some equality and
we have some fraternity. We work we
believe that and when it's removed from
us
we respond. Now the first people to
respond are always
for some reason why we don't know.
France. And so with the Gileon,
they lost 11 people's lives. I think
there were 1,700 serious injuries. Many
people lost one eye.
And yet they succeeded.
They succeeded.
Well, I you know, I did sell my house
and uh now I rent a house in in the
countryside uh which gets quite cold in
the winter time. But these things are
not they're no longer concerns. First of
all, uh I'm old. I don't have a worry. I
don't have to make a family. I don't
have to hold a house together. I can
live in a tent if I want.
You're a very dangerous grandpa. I can
feel it. [snorts]
So, I'm happy with that. And for 3 years
I've lived out of a suitcase. You know
this I've been to 50 countries. I've
been Berlin eight times and so on in
pursuit. So I don't worry about that.
You know um I don't worry about co I I
act sensibly. I don't make enemies of
government. It's not my job to make
enemies. My job simply is to find a path
for Julian to get out of the mood.
That's all. That's all my job is.
Mask
administr
[gasps]
journalist and an intellectual
who hasn't broken any laws to be in a
maximum security jail 22 hours a day in
a cell? I don't think so. As for medical
treatment, Julian Assange is in the
complete disposal of the jail
administration.
If he doesn't want to take a medicine,
it goes on his list and it produces in
court. if he does want to take a
medicine, it's equally goes on his list
and produces in court. So [snorts]
with the vaccines, he he has been
vaccinated, of course, because all of
the prisoners in the jail are
vaccinated. So he has no choice in this.
He has no choice about anything.
He has no control over his body. He has
only choice as to what he may think
about from this day or from me sorry
from this minute to the next minute.
What his thoughts are are his. The rest
is in the complete control of the jail
administration because it's a maximum
security prison.
Everything that a prisoner does in a
maximum security prison is supervised.
his cell is searched on a regular basis.
So that's Julian's circumstance.
There is video camera.
room where they place us when I visit
Julian. There's uh a camera every 3 m in
the ceiling.
But in the middle where they place the
others, it's uh has a mezzanine uh void
above [snorts] and there's no cameras
there. But they always place us under
the highfidelity. So they can have a a
lip reading uh programs. Yeah.
highfidelity lip reading program and we
are always placed under the I speak to
Julian like this and when I have to
discuss something I speak like that so
that they can't read my mouth. Yeah,
that's the
kidnapping the Julian Assange.
about the CIA. I'm completely cynical.
Um, you know, I just um can't understand
uh how it took so long to reveal what
they're the CIA up to, you know. Um,
they
Yeah. How can I say this?
Just let I'll get a grip of this. Okay.
The CIA now run the drone drone
programs. The drone programs have
targeting. When you read that a wedding
party has been destroyed or a cortage
funeral has been destroyed,
this is targeting. It's not accidental.
It's not because they saw a group of
people dancing that they sent the drones
down and blew it up. They destroy the
high points
of a society. The high point of a
society is when two young people come
together and the resources of the
society and the all of the training, all
of the uh living culture is represented
by those two youthful people coming
together to produce the next generation.
That is the high point of human
existence.
It provides the next generation and
provides continuity for the culture and
worship of the ancestors in the sense
that the immediate ancestors take the
young people and push them forward.
Well, when you destroy that, you
destroy the inner growth and inner life
of that society.
They know that. They also know that the
other high point [snorts] of a society
is a funeral cotage.
The we give thanks
and we celebrate the life of the person
who has died and is being buried. So we
all gather together and we say thank you
goodbye and we celebrate their life uh
in different ways. Some people cry,
others, like the Irish, they have a
drink or whatever. But we celebrate.
They destroy that.
They destroy it.
Let me let me let me uh let let me have
another question.
SQL
Franc.
Well,
main [clears throat]
You know, [snorts] uh
there's a beautiful thing. It's called
patience. [snorts] And with patience,
you'll see the bodies of your enemies
float down the river before you
um and finishing my last statement with
the uh um the CIA and its targeting
policies. These are policies. Policy.
You can't say it enough. I say it three
times to call upon the forces of life to
witness. Policy, policy, policy. The
destruction of 7 million people in the
Middle East was a policy.
the creation of 37 million refugees over
the last 20 years wandering the world
looking for homes and ruining the
societies that they came from and
endangering the societies that they move
into is a policy
policies policies policies and of course
I don't
imagine
taking up their way of seeing life,
buying a gun and shooting people. I
would like to see them humiliated. Of
course, I would like to see them removed
from power. Of course, I would like to
see decent policies and I would like to
see that these institutions
that are so embedded in thinking about
death
in order to organize life that the
absurdity of that proposition. I would
like to see that changed very much and I
work towards that in my own simple and
modest way. Yeah, I think that answers
your question. I'm not sure.
Yes.
Uh I did uh go without food for 3 weeks
once. Um I got rather thin.
Um it wasn't very wise thing to do but I
suppose I could I have thought of it.
Yeah, I have thought of uh self
emulation.
you know to go and set myself on fire. I
have thought of that but
is it's somehow contraindicative
that
they are destroying Julian so I destroy
myself and they continue to destroy
Julian
also I have I have a daughter this big
you know sever her name is uh what would
she do
so we're report. We just do
um we do the the best we can. How do I
say this? We do absolutely everything we
can and we remain sensible and humane.
This is our job.
Without that, we are nothing. We are
like them. that they sign another
uh legal instrument further torturing
Julian Assange or they have a discussion
and a meeting. How can we take the f
focus of this event, the persecution of
Julian Assange away from the crimes that
we have all committed and make the focus
on Julian. Okay. Well, this is how we'll
do it. will make the will suggest to the
judge that she decides not to extradite
Julian Assange to America because he's
sick.
And so everybody focuses on Julian
Assange, not the 7 million people who
are slaughtered, not the paw of grief
that hangs like a dark cloud over the
entire Middle East. Not the 37 million
people looking for resettlement. Not the
[snorts] million people that moved into
Germany looking for resettlement. Not
the 500,000 that moved into Italy
looking for resettlement. Not the
650,000
that have passed through France looking
for a life somewhere or other. Not that
we so they we focus everybody focus on
Julian you know is suffering this he
might commit suicide and you have an
entire hearing two days hearing with the
Lord Chief Justice of uh of the high
court in in England focusing on and
arguing about Julian's well-being and
the CIA's uh um instead of looking at
the crimes that these people have
committed
over the last 20 years which have been
exposed by Wikileaks and Julian Assange.
That in itself
is a a crime we fight against.
I I'll move to the United States and
continue the to to fight. I won't, you
know, I can't give in. I mean, no, I
have no thought of giving in. I just uh
I don't use hope as a tool. I don't use
optimism as a tool. are just what comes
before me each day. I tackle to the best
of my ability on the day. Of course, the
ability uh one's ability goes up and
down. You know, some days you're good,
some days you're not so good. But, uh
that's what I do. I never use hope as a
a tool of energy. I give hope to others.
Of course, I'm not I don't like to be
mean, but I don't use it to get out of
bed. I get out of bed because there's
this to do, that to do, and that to do.
Well, you know, after the hearing on the
27th and 28th, a lawyer outside the
court told me, he said it'll be a couple
of weeks. Then another lawyer rang me up
and said it'll be John a minimum six
weeks. And then I read in the paper
it'll be uh from Alexander Mccurus. Uh I
read it'll be sometime mid January. So,
you know, like uh how long is a piece of
string burning?
The if the extradition is accepted,
Julian will appeal to the uh to the
Supreme Court. Equally, if the United
States if the exedition is refused, the
United States will appeal will appeal.
Okay. [snorts]
After two years on remand, Julian has
the privilege, if call it that, uh uh to
appeal to the European Court of Human
Rights for a bail application.
the
European Court of Human Rights will
decide and probably will say yes, more
than likely will say yes, you can have
bail. But the United Kingdom doesn't
have to take any notice of that ruling.
It can say go jump in the lake. Um they
have there was the working group on
arbitrary detentions conclusion in 2017
and that the that Julian was arbitrarily
detained. They reissued their
determination in stronger language in
February 2018.
In both cases the United Kingdom said
we're not interested.
Um
equally Niels Melza in the United
Nations Rapotur on torture professor of
international law at Glasgow University
issued a report stating that Julian was
being psychologically tortured over a
period of 10 years and that he
characterized it as a a slow motion
murder before our eyes. Al and he took
to the jail two specialist psychiatrists
to evaluate you or medical people who
specialize in these matters. Equally he
outlined the abrogation of due process
procedure irregularities
and abrogation of human rights
that uh Julian had undergone. Oh, and
the conventions of asylum. All of those
areas, particular legal contraventions,
he outlined them in his report and they
said not interested.
[gasps]
Well, it was so uh Julian made
application and and Stella of course
made application to the prison governor.
Could they get married? They also made
application to the Department of
Justice. Could they get married? This
was delayed and delayed and delayed. So
Julian's lawyers said that we'll take
you to court
uh after a certain date 24 hours from
that date. They said yes. A lawyer rang
me up a dear friend uh and said John
they would have been smashed in court if
they'd have taken it to court. So they
only surrendered
from force majour. That's all. From no
human impulse other than exercise of
power did they surrender. And that's
been consistent with the United Kingdom
treatment of Julian Assange. I thought
previously,
if I could add this, I thought
previously
that all of this stemmed from the United
States, that the United States was the
magician behind the curtain.
But I've changed my mind because for 12
years
the United Kingdom has exercised malice.
[snorts] Savage malice
as usual.
As usual. Yes. As usual. As we see last
week in the fishing dispute. Savage
malice. Unscrupulous
scandalous
lies and calumnies. So British
12 years
uh what else have they done? Vicious
hatred. So Julian's as you know Julian
uh part of his
philosophy or approach was transparency.
They hate it. They with vicious hatred
they attack transparency. They say yes,
yes, yes. But then you put in a a
freedom of application to the Crown
Prosecuting Service who has between 9
and 11,000 pages on Julian and you get
350 pages.
So they hate transparency.
Each month, each of the editors of the
major newspapers and uh television
outlets in the United Kingdom meet in
the Department of Defense.
Can you imagine? They meet in the
department of defense building
and the department of defense instructs
them on the areas of sensitivity,
current areas of sensitivity.
I mean this is you know I mean it I
describe it that way. they presented as
uh as uh the department of defense
assisting the production of news and
transparency and whatever but it's
actually further control as you know the
United Kingdom has D notices if they
issue a D notice
you can't tell anybody that you've have
the D notice nor can you tell anybody
what the subject matter of The D notice
is
a D notice against an so for example
they come in and put you a D notice to
you and they say oh you had this
conversation with John Shipton I'm sorry
you can't say to anybody you had the
conversation that would be against the
law and put you in jail and you can't
publish the conversation that's against
the law and put you in jail goodbye
that's what they're like
Fore.
Yes. Um I I do uh with the assistance of
uh John Pilia um who by the way is back
in hospital uh with Neonia. I worry for
him because he's very close friend. You
might send him your regards if you get
time. I'll give you his email address.
um
and with his assistance and with uh John
Lare
who recently you know died his last book
gives us
well
they're not going to tell us but we can
get a picture of the concerns of the a
certain strata upper middle class of uh
[snorts] the United Kingdom by the
production of what they produce what
literature. So you have John Lare, you
have Graham Green, Ian Fleming, all uh
George Orwell, all concerned with
[snorts] duplicity,
spying, silence. Well, we all like some
silence sometimes. Um deceit and uh
sacrifice and betrayal.
All of those books are concerned with
that. And that's a stream of literature
uh [snorts] that uh is in in uh in the
United Kingdom. Well, in England, not
the United Kingdom. Um very different
say from France with Alexander Dumas for
example. So you see the cont the
strength of that contrast uh [snorts]
where uh the uh French
inference in literature is upon the
romantic
elevation above
the difficulties of life in order to
transcend.
You might say it's romantic. I don't but
people do. So uh in contrast to uh
England where their
intricate interweaving of deceit,
silence, betrayal
um and duplicity is a common factor.
Yeah.
Oh, well, you know,
at the moment I I don't have a a good
feel for the future of the West or
Europe. Um
um because the vigor of outlook
has moved to Russia which remakes itself
and China which has a different method
of government where uh finance is a
public utility and uh in in Europe
finance is a private utility. So the
accumulation of capital and the
financialization
of our societies
is not
well it's not encouraging to me to think
that my my daughter little daughter um
will be
forever in her life paying off mortgage
or whatever. and the [snorts]
deliberate uh escalation of value of
real estate.
We say real estate, we we don't mean
real estate. The escalation of value of
a home. Now in Melbourne, [snorts]
there's such a shortage of homes that
there's Facebook pages for young people
to sh for sharehouses. you know they get
on Facebook would you like to share and
so on and they have sharehouses so youth
can no longer have enough money to form
families you can't form a family there's
not enough money so you have [snorts] to
live with your mom and dad or or you
can't you don't form a family or in
Germany for example
uh 39% of women over 40 don't have any
children
uh
in France is similar to say I'm sorry to
say in [snorts] uh uh in Italy it's even
worse that people can no longer form a
family. This is just disaster.
I have some uh friends who
uh ex secret service people
Australia
Australia. Yeah. Uh none from uh secret
uh
divide it. Let's divide it up. One of
the techniques
in my position would be for people to
come and divert our interests down blind
alleys. Go and do this. We'll give you
some help and some money, but go off and
do that. And that's happened to me in
the in the United States. I took no
notice. And that's happened to me in the
United Kingdom. My two friends who
[snorts] are in uh one or other aspect
of secret services in Australia are very
frank and helpful and guarded. Yeah.
Yeah.
Dilbassad.
[laughter]
Well, it's certainly not true. He's
still there. And the Russians are very,
very capable people.
I'm not so sure. When you go to
Salsbury, they cannot do shop properly.
[laughter]
Yeah. Yeah. He's
they're like tourists
like Yeah. Like uh but the Petro and
Borisop there turn up all the time. I
saw pictures of them flying an airplane
the other day.
The Petro and Borishop. [laughter]
So this comedy spread right around the
world and it's become you know
ridiculous. So equally, you know, the
Russians uh dragging for what purpose?
Dragging Julian out of the the embassy.
For what purpose? You know, to what end?
Very skilled and practical diplomatic
core in Russia, foremost in the world at
the moment. Uh, [snorts]
France used to be foremost. But anyway,
uh, foremost in the world at the moment
is going to drag Julian out and have a
gunfight outside Harold. It's just, you
know, fantasy. Just a complete fantasy.
There was some uh years ago when Julian
had a lot of visitors uh in the embassy,
there was some talk that he had a a hole
in the floor that he'd go out and he go
into one of the Harrods tunnels because
Harrods has a lot of tunnel and go out
through the Harrods tunnels and go
nightclubing.
It's, you know, it's just a a just a a
fantasy that people plan. Yeah. I get
impatient with it actually.
politician, the first
Yes. You know the the the substance
and the strength of a government is the
unity
of the polity behind it.
This is vital.
The only strength that a government has
is the strength of its people. Not its
arrangements. Not drinking crystal with
this woman who came to Paris the other
day. I can't even remember her name.
Harris or something. She's the vice
president. Ah, of United States, the
small country who every time ah yes,
this one
they closed the road so we couldn't
cross the road as as she went to to
visit. uh um [snorts]
and uh um
I don't want to how can I say this and
the ministers of state of France
[snorts] having crystal with the
minister of state of the United States
or whoever
that's not the security and the unity of
the country the security and unity the
strength of the country and its security
rests within the population, their
education, their health, their belief in
the efficacy of the government and the
understanding that the government won't
go to water or won't isn't
uh
afflicted with cowardice. When a bully
comes along, it can find a way. guile,
cunning, deceit,
find a way to protect the country rather
than saying, "Oh, well, you can buy half
of all trans. You can't buy it all."
This sort of, you know, weak need
cowardice. And we all understand that
and we remove support from the
government and we concern ourselves with
distractions.
And the government sees this. And when
it has to
do really important things like organize
a pandemic and a response to a pandemic
and get scientists to look at the
pandemic closely and get other
scientists to evaluate the statistics
and get other scientists to
evaluate
why the United States wants us all to
the entire world to vaccinate.
for business.
This is to to to protect the economy
for whatever reason. For whatever reason
our belief in the government that it'll
go about that will give this the
government strength to once it's made
its decisions
to uh institute them and we will we will
believe we'll take it up. We'll assist.
But after
after
well I don't want to insult people but
after Ol soft testicle or sarosi who
wants to be president so badly he says
I'll make a deal with you. You can take
command of the force of frappe under
NATO and I can be president
and they say okay you can be president.
I think he's was known as uh as
Yeah.
[laughter]
did
lesson.
Um, c [clears throat] can you repeat the
question?
I I wouldn't
I wouldn't think so. The I think uh
[snorts] the greatest fear of
the people who tortured Julian is
that they will be held culpable for
their crimes. That's their fear. They
don't they want to be able to embark
upon these murderous adventures
without
punishment.
That's their fear. Their fears are
practical, not impractical. I don't
think they know the meaning of truth
except to say uh well it's true that uh
you know uh my wife is going out with
somebody else or you know that I don't
think they know what truth is frankly.
Um well the main reason I think is that
France along with
other nations
believed that there
would be a a practical solution.
found
diplomatically
by the United Kingdom and
Sweden
and to a certain extent the United
States because in 2010
uh Vice President Biden said that this
matter will embarrass the first
amendment of our constitution. So we
don't want to go there. So I I don't
Yeah, I think people waited
and in the end they waited too long.
I think that uh it
speaking as I imagine France, I think uh
because uh the
justice minister in the government of uh
Olan
discussed publicly
uh
asylum for Julian.
So it is a thought within the structure
of government in France. But uh the
opportunities
and the danger of offering have grown
since we witness more and more
commitment from the United Kingdom and
the United States to destroy Julian and
to destroy the idea [snorts] of holding
on the internet data which allows the
growth
of a forum amongst the populace. And the
forum
can
precipitate out and do its own analysis
and come to conclusions with themselves
and their friends, family, their
community, their uh wider community,
their electorates that certain actions
they don't want. They don't want the
government to do this, they'd rather do
that. Holding that information on the
internet creates a well a giant forum
for discussion and that discussion
precipitates out meanings.
You can see the results. It just if I
can run this past you I'll try and do it
uh in an interesting fashion. So the
[snorts] Guantanomo Bay files, the
collateral murder, we saw the murder of
18 people, the Iraq war files, the
Afghan war files. [snorts] They
descended upon the populace of the
United States and the English-speaking
countries in with more effect than the
non-English-speaking countries. It
precipitates down like rain. and soaks
into the soil of the culture.
Empires are very slow to turn around.
But soaking into the
the [snorts] soil, the culture, it had a
result and that result is manifested in
two things.
An apherism rose up held by the people.
an apherism rising up as a historical
fact.
Endless wars that didn't come from top.
It rose up from the bottom to describe a
circumstance
of a political circumstance of a state
action. Endless wars. Then slowly the
support by the populace was removed. as
populace became pacific to the wars. Not
anti-war,
not pro-war, but pacific. No war. We
don't want it. We're sick of it.
The wars ended.
Afghanistan stopped. They pulled out a
disaster for them, but great for us.
Iraq war. The phenomenon of Iraq war.
It's over. They're gone.
Guantanamo Bay just about closed. 80
people left there. They can't find
places for them. They want to close it.
That foul excretence on the face of
justice in the world.
The Syria, they're just about gone from
there but been defeated.
The disaster of Libya
recognized by everybody now as a
tragedy.
The lesson of Libya to the other nations
of the world. Recognize now the lessons
of Li. You can't let these people do
anything. They have to be held to law.
So you can see that those revelations
have an effect of stopping wars. One
more example. Oh no, there's three more,
but I'll do one more. One more.
Okay.
One of the cables
released, an American cable from the
embassy, the
the green zone in Baghdad to the State
Department. It was released by
Wikileaks, published,
equally published, of course, by
Krypton, John Young's site, and equally
published by Free Tug. But we deal with
this one.
A group of American soldiers went into a
house which is an extended family and
murdered everybody, the children, moms,
dads, uncles, aunties, brothers,
sisters, the lot. Every single one of
them. Contemplating that they'd get
caught for this crime, they called in an
air strike on the house and obliterated
from the earth all evidence forever of
the existence of that family. gone.
That was described in a cable. The it
was read by
members of the Iraqi parliament somehow
some magic way. We don't understand how
that parliament of the that destroyed
country gathered together the courage,
the strength of will, the guts
and said we will not
sign the status of forces agreement, the
sofa. We will not sign it. Any American
or soldier, any allied soldier, American
and its allied [snorts] that commits a
crime in Iraq will be tried for that
crime. That's it. They withdrew the
troops. A revelation
stopped a war. Really important. A
revelation stopped the war
in Iraq. And they had to go about it in
a different way and cultivate ISIS and
all that sort of thing. But however a
revelation stopped a war, your work as
journalists can stop wars. Another one.
Another one. The cables also covered the
removal of the Chaos Islanders from
their islands. All of them. Every single
one, even the dogs were taken from Chaos
Islands and dumped in Mauritius.
One of the islands was given over to the
United States for an air base we all
know as Diego Gthia.
The Chaos Islanders and their lawyers
saw the cable and took those
took the United Kingdom to the
International Court of Justice and won.
The United Kingdom appealed and they
prevailed. The Chaganders prevailed
again and they're seeking compensation.
Another one,
an American lawyer who lives in England,
Clive Stafford Smith, established an NGO
called Reprieve
and it concentrated on getting people
[snorts] prisoners out of Guantanamo
Bay. As you know, most of the people
there were innocent of any crime.
The cables revealed that an English
citizen or a UK citizen, a British
citizen was being tortured by pieces
being cut off his dick, his penis.
He was able to argue the freedom of
people. So that's another circumstance.
So stop [snorts] wars,
bring justice,
bring justice to the chaos islanders and
compensation. And finally,
environmentalism.
Wikileaks published [snorts] an
a
this is a bit ugly on Figura which is an
English company that took
a UK company that took e-waste and
dumped it off the coast of Africa
poisoning the fishingund
I think it's 127 forgive me my memory
not accurate for numbers
villages. The villages are destroyed.
They can't eat this. But 127 died of
poison, themselves, pissing
themselves, unable to walk, nervous uh
deterioration. You know, their nerves
didn't operate anymore.
[snorts]
This was published and uh this enabled
lawyers and
NOS's to assist and to seek compensation
and that dumping of e-waste off the
coast of Africa stopped.
technism,
you know,
structurally the worst thing I've ever
read was uh the notes by John Yu who was
the attorney general of the United
States arguing that that uh that torture
was okay was okay to torture every
single country in the world the United
Nations in fact America itself had
banned torture and then John U the
attorney general of the United States in
the Bush 2 government argues
convincingly ly for them the torture is
okay. After that it's open slather,
black sites in Poland, black sites in
the Ukraine, on and on it goes. So
[snorts]
I
particular circumstances of torture like
uh that uh Khalif being waterboarded
84 times and losing his marbles
completely
and just becoming a zombie. The point of
of course of water boarding is not to
get you to confess to anything. It's to
get you to confess to a particular
thing.
People don't realize that that the point
of this torture is to get you to say a
particular thing
that they want to to hear.
Yeah. That they, you know, blew up the
towers or whatever it was, whatever the
the saddest have in their mind. But what
what uh I found particularly nauseating
was that the promotion of sadism as a
policy of the United States government.
That's uh you know that's out there way
out there in the areas of being
shocking.
Well, yeah.
It's the law of life, you know, that you
there's only one thing you can't forgive
and that's attacks against children.
The rest you can forgive. It's human to
her. But attacking children, it's
finished. I can't go there. I can't go
there.
France Jul
you know I make it a rule to only have a
private conversation with politicians
and not to meet them if possible. Uh I I
work uh I work from uh you know the
ground up and
that's my job you know it's to work from
the ground upwards. I leave negotiations
with politicians
and senior bureaucrats to other people
who for example
[snorts]
uh if you propose a certain thing you
know a certain avenue
uh that Julian have to be uh say given a
visa to uh uh come and seek asylum in
France. If one proposes that have to
have the mechanisms, the knowledge of
the mechanisms, the knowledge of the
administrative techniques, the knowledge
of the laws wherein this would fit. And
I don't have that knowledge. That's a
professional circumstance. So if the
work that we do from the ground up
causes enough political
circumstance for the professionals to
put their minds onto how to solve the
problem in the practical circumstances
of blending laws of thinking of
diplomatic face saving ways that's their
job my job is to you speak to you. Yeah.
It might can't be sorry
no you know I just we let's yeah this is
a good subject and we can start there
this is what we start where we started
an hour and a half ago okay Julian
Wikileaks was first registered in France
Wikileaks fought its first court case
for publication in France Julian at that
time lived in the Marray had a French
family.
He
was on his way back to France to his
family when arrested in in the United
Kingdom where he's now been for 13
years. It's a long, you know, it's a
long journey. It's 26 miles across the
the the channel and now takes 12 13
years to get there. So in that the the
um in [snorts] that circumstances
affiliation I have a grandchild in
France. I'm concerned
in my way for France. Uh [snorts] you
know my modest way for France. I enjoy
being here. Um the gifts. So go from
there to the gifts that Julian Wikileaks
made to the elites of France and
consequently
to the people of France. The
understandings that we just rapidly
covered the uh
NSA listening into the president's phone
calls, private phone calls, mind you,
ringing his wife and saying, you know,
can we have a bottle of wine with dinner
or something? private phone call, the uh
manipulation of the French electoral
system, the revealing that that how it
was done and when it was done, the uh
listening in and manipulation of the the
uh European Community Bank. Oh, for
God's sake, so important. diverting the
uh facilitating
the revealing of the NSA and the GCHQ,
facilitating [snorts] the stealing and
plundering of the high points of French
technology from five really vital French
companies.
So, you know, Julian
is France.
for
Julian
control
No, I I think France can guarantee
Julian's
I'm not so sure about it.
I think they could, you know,
in Corsica
[laughter]
in Corsica we can protect Julian,
you know, because Corsican guys has got
honor code.
Yes. Yes.
And they respect it until the death.
Yes. I I understand. I um
well
this is interesting.
As I understand it, there were 17
attempts against Doul's life while he
was president. Those attempts were
prevented by a Corsican criminal
and his bodyguard was organized by a man
who uh would had colorful [laughter]
and successfully
prevented. So I I believe that Julian
would be more or less safe here.
[snorts]
However, the reasons
for what arrangements
President Macron and his uh foreign
service advisor have made have made with
the United States over the robbery of
$90 billion.
I can't guess that. However, I did see
that uh the the an official state visit
was made by the vice president Camila
Harris to to France as a sort of an
apology. Well,
it's an insult.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's a insult.
They send the second knife
to ask apologize.
It's a joke.
I I think so. I mean, you know,
and you know what? We don't have any
American ambassador in France. We only
have a charm miss.
Okay.
It proved the respect that they've got
for us. It's it's nice. It's so nice.
Sorry to destroy destroy.
No, no. You know, I I tried to make it
look ridiculous that that they have this
they block off the chams and they drive
up and down with the cortage cost France
money uh as a favor to France for
stealing $90 billion. It's very comic.
You know, this is uh unsatisfactory. And
I speculate, well I don't I read that
people speculate that over [snorts] the
next 5 years
because of the color revolution against
the Gaul in 68 which shocks me because I
was young then I was on the wrong side.
Um but uh uh then the understandings of
color revolutions
now how it works out
that over the next 5 years France will
make every effort and so will
assoc associated companies. So sorry
associated countries with France will
make every effort to prepare partially
each year, each month, each minute
for further independence so that this
sort of thing doesn't happen again.
There's no other way. You think there's
another way. You think that to be
continually plundered by the United
States is somehow going to make France
wealthy, the population healthy, the
population educated. Forget about it.
There's only one way to stop the
plunder, and that's more independence.
Yeah.
Or nuke them. We can nuke them.
We can nuke them.
Well, you have the foreh.
It is I imagine the centerpiece of a
European army.
is a um a great Frenchman uh who
established uh the Arasmus project
uh
Franker
Pasam he's dead since maybe six or seven
years
but he he was a I corresponded with him
and I I read
brilliant guy
brilliant absolutely brilliant he
speculated now it's 10 years passed and
well 11 years passed that what would
happen what had to happen was that the
fore
become the centerpiece of a European
army. So I believe at negotiation with
Biden after the stealing of the $90
billion that the European army has
the policy of a European army is now
growing and is to a fullness.
We need to pray for it, but I'm not so
sure.
Well, Frank said it's going to come
No, no. Just one thing I find that
everything that's everything
comes up from the mass of us that the
the an inventive capacity rests within
the soul of the nation or to use
uh not religious talk but rest within
the within within the people themselves.
And so it's all it requires again is for
us to converse with each other over our
concerns. And this creates a a
social political circumstance and a
historical change. That's all that's
required. We don't need to to uh make
any uh special efforts to go to the sub
one or something although education is
important but to converse with each
other over our concerns and you will see
that the gile will manifest itself again
in other
gile
will manifest itself again and again and
And this is my belief.
Oh. Oh, you know um I like uh uh one
book I like is
uh Fakulta on madness. I like uh
[snorts] uh Gor Bati on death. Um,
and I like uh Frederick uh nature uh on
the understanding that uh
the that how can I say this? I like
Frederick nature on the understanding
that belief that you willed it that you
w your life increases your capacity to
order your life. You believe that you w
it. I willed it thus. Even the worst
thing you've done in your life, I w it
thus. It fleshes out the soul and gives
you a lot of strength. And this is
important for um to burden yourself with
guilt all the time is corrosive to
action.
So take no notice of people who say
you'll use too much petrol and kill the
birds if you drive down to the shop.
Forget about it. Don't use any guilt.
Just use practicality. If I walk to the
shop, I'll get a bit of exercise and I
might be able to say hello to my friend
as I bump into on the way. That's the
circumstance. Not the circumstance that
I feel bad cuz I used a little bit of
petrol and went up in the air and the
bird died. It's absurd.
Just the practical circumstances of
acting in your family's interest
foremost and then your own interest
second. some other books for our
communities to advice.
Uh well, I I I
[snorts]
don't have any in mind. Too many books.
Oh yes, just get on with it. just uh and
take no notice of old fogies like me.
Get on your This is the a really
fabulous thing that the uh the times how
do you say the times in French? K.
the times the the zitgeist
your zitgeist
your zit your times are so absolutely
different than mine when I grew up our
concerns were housing education
distribution of wealth the building of a
country because it was just after the
war these were Our concerns the cohesion
of a country, the pro provision of
health care, the provision of
opportunities of education to men and
women equally. These were our concerns.
Your
zitgeist your times are so different.
And so I have no
[snorts]
uh I have no advice that is suitable
that fits in
to your times. That's for young people
because my times are so different. It's
like well I think they say the past is
another country. Just get on with it.
take no notice of of uh anybody who
wants to make you feel guilty. Um I
think it says in the Bible somewhere
that Satan is uh the person who
makes you want who wants to make you
feel guilty. Guilt is [snorts]
a corrosive pain brought to you by
accusation from other people.
take some freedom and act in your own
interests and your family's interests.
Join, thank you so much.
Okay.
[music]